in 1995 disney made one of the most
amazing films which truly captures the
emotion found between a single father
and his teenage son and it blew
audiences away but then it disappeared a
goofy movie is probably one of the most
underrated films to come out during the
disney renaissance era but it seems to
have completely vanished from pop
culture mentions aside from an
occasional power line t-shirt but why
did this happen and where did it go also
in this video we're going to discuss how
disney actually intended for this movie
to feel nostalgic in the future when it
was being made
[Music]
in this video we're going to talk about
four things emotion the disney formula
nostalgia and disappearance the first
thing we need to discuss though is why a
goofy movie is such a great film
emotion the movie starts us off with our
main character max goof in a pretty
emotional nightmare
this scene depicts max's main internal
struggle throughout the film that he's
terrified about turning into his dad
goofy it's at this point in the movie
where we realize that the fun-loving and
always kind character goofy is actually
the movie's villain if max is our main
character even though he may make tons
of mistakes along the way then goofy is
the villain because he's the one person
who hinders max from achieving what he
wants in the film which is being cool
and getting the girl max's interactions
in the first few scenes with his friends
and his love interest roxanne perfectly
encapsulate the awkwardness of high
school and new relationships
[Laughter]
also it's so much fun to see carl from
jimmy neutron and paulie shore from
encino man join the cast of voice actors
for the film as max's high school
friends as well as the princess brides
wallace shawn as the school principal
inconceivable
there are tons of scenes which are able
to perfectly show the emotion between a
loving and goofy father and an angsty
teenage son goofy takes the
stereotypical pun making dad to the next
level pushing max's embarrassment to the
extreme by taking him on a cross-country
fishing trip complete with a stop at a
possum themed amusement park
honestly though goofy makes such a great
single dad it's simply a complete lack
of communication that causes the rift
between them leading to what i'd call
anti-chemistry during the song on the
open road the two actually sing in canon
perfectly imitating each other's
melodies but just not at the same time
[Music]
although the two don't exactly see eye
to eye get it they're still able to have
great musical chemistry together you can
definitely tell that there just needs to
be an adjustment in their communication
style or some form of compromise for the
two to exit the realm of anti-chemistry
and enter the realm of true chemistry at
one point in the movie after a huge
fallout the two have this interaction
i've grown up
i've got my own life now i know that
i just wanted to be part of it this
devastating interaction resulted from a
total betrayal of trust on max's part
after being officially named the trip's
navigator by his dad max changed the map
directions and sent them towards los
angeles rather than their fishing
destination so he could see his favorite
musician power line goofy hoping he
wouldn't do this let max keep his
navigator status which ultimately led to
max's betrayal after this betrayal there
are no musical numbers for a good
portion of the movie for an enhanced
emotional effect which brings us to the
next item to discuss the disney formula
disney movies tend to follow a pretty
strict formula for success they're
almost always musicals or include
musical numbers they typically feature a
more traditional family unit they
include what's called an i want song as
well as an intro song and there's almost
always a romantic story at the center of
the plot basically the formula is that a
princess with a desire to do more finds
a guy that fulfills her desire along
with plenty of musical numbers to fill
in some time this movie however diverts
almost completely from this formula
taking its own unique one while the film
does include musical numbers throughout
it takes a different angle on how to
fill out the plot instead of having an
intro song such as mulan's honor to us
all in addition to an i want song such
as ariel's part of your world max sings
after today which accomplishes the
functions of both an intro song and an i
want song
it introduces max as a high school
reject planning something big for the
last day of school before summer begins
and it also shows his deepest desires to
finally be seen as cool and to talk to
roxanne another way the film detracts
from the disney formula is by giving us
a less traditional family unit a single
father and son it's really refreshing to
see a less traditional family on screen
when we're used to seeing the typical
nuclear family in most releases showing
how a single dad is able to reach his
son on a deeper emotional level could
actually be quite inspiring to people
going through similar situations
lastly while there is a romantic story
in the film between max and roxanne it
isn't the central focus instead the
focus is placed upon the relationship
between max and goofy so rather than
being a romantic love story like we see
in most disney movies this film is a
family love story in fact i'd argue that
the song nobody else but you is one of
the most touching love songs we got from
the disney renaissance era
the two most memorable songs from this
movie are definitely eye to eye and
stand out stand out is the song that
every kid wishes they had the guts to
perform on the last day of school so
they can finally be seen as cool and get
the girl so i think it's one of the most
universally relatable songs from the
entire movie eye to eye on the other
hand is the culmination of the plot
resolving the two main conflicts of the
story max and goofy finally lose their
anti-chemistry by seeing eye to eye and
max gets to perform on stage with
powerline to impress roxanne re-watching
this movie you can just tell that
there's something about these songs that
pulls you back into the 1990s in a way
none of the other disney songs from this
era can do you can't help but start to
feel sentimental when listening to these
songs but i actually think disney
intended to make us feel this way when
they were making the movie which brings
us to the next topic nostalgia
rewatching this movie i couldn't help
but think that the creators intended to
make a nostalgia time bomb in a goofy
movie specifically for millennials the
score for the film and the genres chosen
for the musical numbers helped to set
the tone of a 1990s high school movie
and there are tons of little things that
point towards its nostalgic feel like
their phones or manual car windows
at the beginning of the movie max is
seen as somewhat of a marty mcfly type
not really that cool but still talented
and pretty likable after his standout
performance though he basically turns
into the super popular ferris bueller he
becomes the main topic of conversation
in the school and there's even a
sequence where he runs in people's
backyards and through a family's house
just the same as ferris bueller did at
the end of his day off because of these
inclusions and many more you can tell
that the creators of the film truly
wanted kids to put themselves in max's
shoes and upon re-watching the movie
later in life recognize how fondly they
remember those times
life moves pretty fast
you don't stop and look around once in a
while
you could miss it ultimately though
because the movie was seemingly made to
create a feeling of nostalgia it fell
out of popularity pretty quickly as
trends changed which leads us to our
last topic disappearance
a goofy movie seemed to slowly disappear
from pop culture in the years following
its release and this is likely due to
several factors first of all the film
isn't technically considered to be a
part of the disney renaissance because
it was produced by disney movie tunes
and walt disney television animation
rather than walt disney animation
studios you know the studio that brought
us the little mermaid aladdin mulan the
lion king and tons more during this time
disney movie tunes and walt disney
television animation on the other hand
weren't known for releasing films with
such widespread appeal as a movie like
the lion king so audiences had lower
interest in seeing the film upon its
release as well as pretty low
expectations those who did see it
however seem to like it a lot it even
sits with a 70 audience score on rotten
tomatoes which is much better than most
of the direct-to-vhs releases that
disney movie tunes was regularly
releasing although it had a pretty
underwhelming take at the box office it
soon became a movie staple of many
american homes in the 1990s as it was
released on vhs by the early 2000s
however vhs players had gone almost
extinct with the rise of dvds because of
this and its nostalgic intention a goofy
movie slowly began to slip out of
popularity aside from an occasional
mention on social media or intermittent
merchandise sales this movie has
somewhat vanished and it's sad to see
because a goofy movie is truly one of
disney's best films from this era and it
teaches several great lessons it'll be
interesting to see if this happens with
any of disney's more recent releases and
whether a goofy movie will ever find its
way to a featured film slot on disney
plus also i forgot to mention how
amazing that cheese on the pizza looked
i'd eat it for every meal of every day
if i could i can't believe you man
anyways that's gonna be all for today if
you liked what you saw maybe check out
the video on your screen for some
different content i make videos on
basically anything that interests me in
the world of entertainment also don't
forget to like and subscribe as it truly
does help me out and thanks for watching
rocket riley
you're still here
it's over
go home